[Music]
and I need money and news submitted by I
miss David Dunkin Donuts manager was
arrested after creating a fake employee
to collect an extra paycheck so like a
manager created this fake and then a new
paycheck comes in and they just like
maybe they're gonna interview with
themself and everything do you work well
with other people
yes I work it may be multiple person
maybe he mrs. Doubtfire dit and kept
changing for his own interview Oh like
bad like six different characters just
so he won't get caught that's right I
like how you guys are thinking it's a
guy Oh ladies can scam - it's a lady are
you got the best camera so she already
yeah they come built-in like how are you
still get laid is beyond me Oh honestly
these jobs back I would paint good money
for that is good my boy why don't you
come out you wait how much oh my god
I'm down five hundred bucks that's what
a [ __ ] lot yeah what are you doing
watching then what are you doing while
they're boning eating popcorn
hey we're bowling shirt you Bobby slap
me I buy more rugs okay we're diving 500
yeah bar you actually down resist a bit
no we're actually down you actually have
sex while she watches yeah yeah but she
has that porn I could buy two rugs
living space is cute yeah scented
runtime not let me space this clearance
section on the website I just bought two
of them can I just say you better put on
a [ __ ] show you better possible
missionary do whatever is not that what
have you paid it's like 45 seconds
thirty am i right i come quick there you
go
well then they do it under the covers
you'll see [ __ ] oh I don't want that no
I want to see but but but you've got a
nice butt okay thank you
you like but multiple butts yeah all
right so multiple booty allottee all
right so this woman her name is Marcia
she's 29 years old she is a manager at
Dunkin Donuts and it turns out that she
clocked in 235 hours until she was
arrested
oh she they're saying that the fake
employee was paid 865 per hour total for
a total of more than 1,600 oh that's it
that's not that much scam for long
enough yeah she was actually working
there so she got double pay yeah and
honestly she's only making $8 an hour if
you double that that's barely minimum
wage in California I don't blame her I'm
having like getting it from her point of
view like let's see SH as a matter she
makes like I don't know 15 or 20 hours
an hour getting $28 an hour I was pretty
good it's like a pretty big chunk but
maybe I thought she's oh yeah yeah but
you know she should have had five more
employees yep she's an hour always go
big
I'm surrounded by doughnuts all day
that's payment enough for me hmm I
wonder if they get in trouble for eating
the supplies this is what she looks like
she loves mugs like she's pissed that
she got caught like it's their fault
she's like god damn it reminds me y'all
played yourself I think a lightly
honestly if you were asking my opinion
but she looks like that's not that shape
where it's like [ __ ] around I can see
the eyes or like the those good eyebrows
no gray of the great of the gray type
great typing great that's what you had
to say yeah she literally looks okay she
got caught yeah y'all let me get back to
work yeah
so the way she got caught is the owners
the store's owner they they said I don't
know exactly how but they somehow
thought that something was suspicious
and they looked at the timesheets and
they looked at the paperwork that they
had and they gathered all of that
presented their case to the police and
that's when they arrested her that's how
you catch people through accounting yeah
but you know why honestly it's not like
this is a big-ass [ __ ] Wall Street
job where she stole millions of dollars
she obviously has only seen on 8,000
bucks if she needs it that's a real dick
of the owners to be like we're gonna
compile all this evidence this girl's
life might be ruined for a while she
clearly needs money they could have just
pulled her aside and been like yo we got
papers and receipts don't [ __ ] do
this again I don't know if I could do
that you know because I think because
this jail I think just because it was so
elaborate and she went through so much
trouble like if she was stealing from
the register I would be way more lenient
with that but my thing is like it's not
even a lot of money it's a foul it's not
I think the fact that she was so
elaborate she thought it out so well I'm
like what others she's doing yeah if
this was my child even I would be like
no no no cuz because it's about like so
with the Y yeah
who's my child I beat the [ __ ] out of
them for getting caught nice video you
piece of [ __ ] I didn't watch you guys
have sex I'm kind of like it's it's
really not that much
and in so ok I'm assuming that like
they're reasonable people right and she
came to them and maybe she didn't come
up come up to him ask for a raise or
anything like what if she did see that
see that's that's that she'll Mulder
she's the best of all those other ones
that saw where's this from and where did
you go Tennant Florida Oh your tail
that'll be more
armored armadillo give me the zip code I
was like girl the penny Pinellas
Pinellas County that's not far from my
cuts : penis county Pinellas I think
that this is a pretty smart lady
oh yeah or like it's hella smart I feel
like you remembered the movie kiss me if
you can we're like at the end of the
movie that he gets hired by like the
government to [ __ ] do this [ __ ] to
help them cause like this is pretty good
scam oh you should tweet them back I'll
tweet you mean the Dunkin donut owner
should hire her or the government just
just to find scams cuz that's pretty
[ __ ] smart like Duncan corporate or
something that's like how they catch
hackers and then they hire them
yeah like that that's true
good point she's not that good I guess
it's just it's just too dumb she just
getting started if I was if I was
working at Dunkin Donuts I'd grab a
[ __ ] pocket full of that donut mix in
my pocket every day and then save it in
the bag make my own donuts and go to a
farmer's market and [ __ ] sell those
donuts what do you call them pocket
pocket donuts oh that's a dope I
wouldn't call pocket burners cuz then
people would be less likely to buy them
cuz it sounds gross right like you got
lint in your pocket and I want it on my
dong zhuo's donut alright we're at we're
alone on this one Joe Lynch doughnuts
hands don't agree five finger doughnuts
yeah that's more like why they call it
man's he's all because they were in my
hands a little while
freshly handed to you so what happened
to this chick is she still in jail she
have to pay a fine yeah well she was
later released she was booked into the
jail later at least so now it's just
pending further legal action is she
fired from Duncan I would say so yeah
that's a good assumption I'm probably
fraud I'll get you fired by my friend
Easter here's a [ __ ] [ __ ] so like I
would deliver weed to him
and he would work we're both morons
right so this is when weed was actually
illegal and and he's he's working the
register at the Sanrio store right there
my dream job
what's the same ran before you like
Hello Kitty stuff this dude comes out
with the [ __ ] apron with the Hello
Kitty on it right and he he gives me the
money and then I'm like back you've been
buying a lot of weed lately like you've
been stressed or what and he's like
knives like I just take it from the
register and you got fired eventually
but it's like this guy's been just
grabbing like one for you one for me
it's the most cutest store to like it's
just it's to play weed with the Hello
Kitty on your Jeff what the hell
Hello Kitty [ __ ] April we did
decriminalize we we wouldn't have teens
stealing from Grande Rio with the
concept I don't want these teens smoking
a useful stoner I don't want them to
smoke because your brain isn't developed
so what happened to Alicia yeah that's
what happened
yeah and you can like alter the way
you're supposed to be if you suck let me
tell you how I started my drug career
Jane well not Mike we got down memory
lane my athleticism in the in the
Olympics of drugs right would you
consider weed not anymore
I would when I was in high school but it
still it's still a drug right like
technically right now it's still a
classic and I'm like a lot of cities
it's not Italy it's it's not an illegal
substance maybe it's questionable but
it's still illegal it's yeah like
alcohol the drug all of is a drug right
so then okay let's classify tobacco all
these things as drugs
I started abusing it at about 13 or 14
years old
and then I didn't stop [ __ ] with
stuff until I was 22 so you probably all
turned your brain a lot how think that's
noticeable I know neuroplasticity brains
are not plastic you can change your
brain
and neurofeedback riddle me this alright
Kelsey okay I've been clean from what I
smoke weed from time to time but I've
been clean clean I don't smoke every day
Geo I'm clean I don't smoking every day
okay my bad okay like once every two
months which is practically like eating
a [ __ ] birthday cake every two months
okay so what's your question
you guys stop interrupting me all right
it's been over 13 years it's been over
13 years does that mean that the brain
being [ __ ] moulded within the prime
years of adolescence does that [ __ ] with
you so hard to the point where it
doesn't matter for weed I think you can
change your brain waves no I think you
can [ __ ] I think the last eight minutes
of everything you just said just
justifies the we yeah yeah no no I only
spent three hours I only slept three
hours and I have a lot of caffeine in my
system we don't want to know about your
thing that you were saying neuro uh
neuro feedback you know you're always
making brain waves rel so you'd be dead
right so the way you can train your
brainwaves is how you develop habits so
like for addiction you have certain
brainwave for your dick your brainwaves
go on like that
your impulsivity is in a pattern and the
way you can break impulsivity is by
Trent brain training which is like bio
hacking so if you're into any of that
[ __ ] Internet you know what I'm talking
about where you can actually go and put
these little magnets on your head and
that you can well they're like brain
readers and you can train your brain way
so when you braid into something good
they go good job brain and when it does
bad it gives you know nothing so he's
already gone I know what you're talking
about all it is it's just positive
[ __ ] it's not behavioral
therapy no it's not there it's literally
an exercise for your brain so I go to
the gym
wow you're really writing it off you
know I'm writing it off just basically
you're just rerouting the triggers below
that every time you reward system fires
put something else in though ok canarian
schemer denarian HB Skinner being sugar
brain how to to act a certain way versus
response for in like 30 minute costs 30
minutes every well the thing is is it's
permanent so once you do it for at least
three or you do that stimulating into
rat brain for the [ __ ] like fixing
addiction with the rat brain and cocaine
okay nothing